[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
that the only person who killed anyone
was the defendant
kyle rittenhouse the trial begins for
the accused kenosha shooter what his
defense is now arguing to a jury that's
where somebody would run
to be protected from a mob that wants to
kill him jury selection in georgia
stretches to day 11. brian buckmeyer is
live with the latest in the trial for
the death of ahmad arbor he's not
responsible for you fingers point
towards assistant director david halls
in the rust movie shooting law and
crimes antoinette levy has more on what
his attorney has to say
my opinion is that he was sane at the
time of the crime experts comment on an
accused murderer's state of mind when he
opened fire at a police officer more
inside the florida courtroom next on law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome to long time daily i'm brian
ross in for brian buckmeyer who's in
georgia covering the trial of the men
accused of killing a mount arbory and of
course here in new york i'm pleased to
be joined by co-host terry austin
a jury is seated and opening statements
are underway in wisconsin for the
accused kenosha shooter teenager kyle
18 year rittenhouse
rittenhouse faces multiple charges
including first degree reckless homicide
intentional homicide and attempted
homicide the charges stem from the 2020
kenosha riots following the shooting of
jacob black a black man who was shot by
a white police officer prosecutors say a
then 17-year-old ridden house drove to
kenosha from illinois and shot three
people during the protest joseph
rosenbaum and anthony huber were killed
gage grosskrotz was injured
rittenhouse could face a life sentence
without parole if convicted he has
pleaded not guilty the defense aims to
argue self-defense claiming that
rittenhouse was in fear for his life a
jury of 20 people was seated late monday
evening with 11 women and nine men
making the final cut opening statements
began on tuesday morning in the state's
opening the prosecutor laid out violent
acts that occurred the night of the
shooting detailing one key fact about
the defendant
the evidence will show
that the only person who killed anyone
was the defendant
kyle rittenhouse
the evidence will show that hundreds of
people were out on the street
experiencing chaos and violence and the
only person who killed anyone was the
defendant kyle rittenhouse
we will show you videos
of some of the events that night
of police
tear gas rubber bullets
and yet the only person who killed
anyone was the defendant
in their opening statement the defense
showed the video where the jury heard
the four deadly shots that were fired
his attorney maintained that the
teenager was acting in self-defense the
night of the shooting
you hear four shots in quick succession
the evidence will show that is kyle
firing at mr rosenbaum as he's trying to
take kyle's weapon from him to use
against him
he begins running down sheridan road
he's not taking his gun
he's not threatening anyone as he's
running down sheridan road what is that
60th the evidence will show that is
where law enforcement is
and that's where somebody would run
to be protected from a mob that wants to
kill him
joining me now is our guest julie
redelman and co-host terry austin and
julie let me begin with you the
prosecution began opening statements of
just spoken statements that we saw
photos and videos from the defense could
one statement be more powerful than the
other because of that
sure i mean look i i was never the type
as a prosecutor as a defense attorney to
kind of use props in order to go through
the opening
but this case is a little different
because the video is everything to this
jury and so while the prosecution i
think was effective in distinguishing
this defendant from every other person
that was out there that day i think the
defense really did a great job of honing
in on those areas that they want to
showing this jury that every act he took
was self-defense now obviously it's up
to the jury to decide at the end of the
day whether the facts support the
defense or the prosecution but i think
both of them did a pretty good job
starting this case out
and terry austin the jury was picked in
just one day and the judge did not allow
a questionnaire sheet could that be a
problem or a factor on appeal
it could be a problem brian because the
constitution under the sixth amendment
requires that every defendant have an
impartial jury of your peers with such a
short voidier and with the lack of a
questionnaire there's no guarantee that
you are going to be able to determine
who is going to be fair and who is going
to be impartial they actually have a
case right now at the supreme court the
boston bomber case where that very
question is at issue so this could be a
problem down the line on appeal all
right thank you very much terry austin
in other legal news robert durst is
indicted for the murder of his missing
wife kathy nearly 40 years later
the indictment came monday days after
durst was moved to a state prison to
begin his life sentence for the murder
of his best friend susan berman durst is
in poor health and has been treated for
covet 19. prosecutors say durst killed
berman because she helped him cover up
the murder of kathy durst and planned to
talk to police about it durst was found
guilty of berman's murder in september
four decades later kathy durr's body has
never been found her family's lawyer
issued a statement on tuesday afternoon
thanking the media for its objectivity
and humanity in making sure robert durst
is held accountable they'll hold a news
conference next week to discuss what
they call a conspiracy to cover up kathy
dursberger and in other top legal news
jeffrey epstein's former girlfriend
appears in court for a free trial
hearing on monday july maxwell faces
federal charges in new york of
conspiracy and enticing minors to travel
to engage in illegal sex acts she's also
charged with sex trafficking of a minor
from 2001 to 2004. maxwell denies the
allegations judge allison nathan has
granted the government's request to let
witnesses testify anonymously the judge
also ruled prosecutors can use the word
victim in front of the jury despite the
defense's request against it maxwell has
been behind bars since her arrest in
july 2020. jury selection begins later
this week and opening statements are set
for november 29th still ahead on law and
crime daily the latest statements from
the attorney for the assistant director
of rust about the deadly shooting that
happened on the movie set
but first jury selection continues in
georgia as we await opening statements
in the trial for the men accusing
accused of killing ahmad arbury brian
buckmeyer is live with the latest
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do i could
i just nothing else i could do you're a
pacifier coming through no not
necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law on crime
network
[Music]
and welcome back to law and crime daily
jury selection nearing an end in georgia
as we prepare for the openings in the
trial for the men accused of killing
ahmad arbury gregory and travis
mcmichael and william roddy bryant faces
charges of malice murder felony murder
and aggravated assault in the shooting
of the 25 year old jogger in february
2020. prosecutors say the father and son
duo gregory and travis mcmichael
followed arbury in a pickup truck as he
ran near his home in georgia travis
mcmichael shot and killed arbury
claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own vehicle
recording on his phone
jury selection has lasted 11 days so far
there are 60 jurors in the pool out of
the 64 needed from that 64 they will
seat the final jury live on the ground
now is georgia is our very own brian
buckmeyer who's bringing us the latest
in the jury selection and brian what are
the takeaways from jury selection so far
yes brian ross so this is what we've
seen so far as you said we started with
60 jurors four away from the magic
number of 64. but 20 jurors the most we
have seen
so far and the judge did comment on that
everyone showed up today showed up for
prospective juror duty now they've been
weaning through some of those
prospective jurors but during the lunch
break we actually heard some chanting of
justice for ahmad and bob rubin the
defense attorney for travis mcmichael
asked the judge to move those people
from the front of the courthouse where
the aubry trial was going on and many of
the prospective jurors walk out it was a
discussion that went back and forth for
some time judge wamsey had definitely
said at one point to say
that he doesn't think he's going to move
them just yet but he may leave it as a
question mark depending on how things
progress the rest of the afternoon
everyone is just waiting for this trial
to start preemptory challenges are
expected to begin tomorrow with opening
statements hopefully on thursday i got
to speak with the mother of ahmad arbory
wanda cooper jones and her civil rights
lawyer lee merritt about the coming
opening statements
at this point
wanda has expressed to me the family has
expressed to me that we want to get this
on with
the family has been dealing with anxiety
and um
you know the weight of it all since this
thing happened since ahmad was murdered
and as we get closer to the day we are
we're comfortable with the panel that
has been pulled together some people we
don't approve of others we we
appreciate have shown up to do their
civic duty
but we're we're just anxious to get the
trial underway now
brian what happened with bob rubin's
complaint about the juror hugging one of
the people chanting justice for allah
outside
so a little bit of background bob
uh sorry brian a little bit of
background brian the people out here
chanting are some of them are relatives
to a mod arbor so the person who came
out we later found out
that that was a cousin of ahmad arbree
or the family of a mod arbore and that
person eventually got disqualified
because as we've seen i would say at
least about 10 or 15 of these
prospective jurors are directly related
to the amount arbory family in one way
shape or form and brian we're hearing
this phrase a silent strike in georgia
what is a silent strike in terms of this
trial and jury selection
so it's a little bit different than what
we see in other states where those
peremptory challenges are done orally on
their record but in georgia there's an
option for a silent strike where the
potential list of jurors will be
prepared in first pass of the
prosecution and they will cross off to
see if they want to strike anyone then
pass the defense to do the same this
appears to be the way that georgia works
because they do not want to create any
bias amongst protects prospective jurors
who may be in the roo in the room you
don't want to see one juror eliminate
one person or another person and so they
do this process as they say a silent
striking process to ensure that there's
no bias between
prospective jurors coming in or out of
the case but that may not may or may not
be the case we have not heard about that
as yet but that still is on the table
here in the case of the death of a mod
arbory and brian this is slowly but
surely coming to an end in terms of
selection
absolutely like i said we're hoping and
praying that peremptory challenges will
start on third on sorry on wednesday and
then most of the defense attorneys have
said they expect opening statements on
thursday all right brian bachmann
georgia thank you so much coming up on
law on crime daily both sides rest in
florida as prosecutors seek justice for
the slain police lieutenant deborah
clayton plus we'll hear from the
attorneys of the assistant director of
the movie rust who described the role he
played in the deadly shooting of the
cinematographer there
[Music]
and welcome back for the first time
we're hearing from the assistant
director of the movie rust about the
fatal shooting of helena hutchins by
alec baldwin law in crimes anjanet levy
tells us what his attorney has to say
a search warrant affidavit quotes dave
halls as saying he should have checked
the gun before handing it to alec
baldwin now halse's attorney says that
checking that gun was not his
responsibility
the armor brought the firearm into the
scene the armor is responsible to make
sure the firearm is safe
the armor opens the revolver opens the
round my client didn't
load the load load the firearm that was
attorney lisa taracco on the story on
fox news discussing dave hall's position
and offering condolences to helena
hutchinson's family halls was on the set
of rust when baldwin shot hutchins while
rehearsing a search warrant affidavit
claims halls grabbed the gun from a prop
cart and handed it to baldwin a claim
his attorney now disputes saying she has
information armorer hannah gutierrez
reid handed the revolver to baldwin the
affidavit also states halls recalled
seeing three rounds in the gun but
couldn't remember whether gutierrez reid
spun the drum for him to inspect
whether or not he handed the firearm
directly to alec baldwin at that moment
or whether the armor handed it directly
to alec baldwin at that moment doesn't
really matter because he didn't load it
he's not responsible for it you can that
can be your perspective on it a criminal
investigation into this shooting is
ongoing and both the d.a and the sheriff
in santa fe county say it's far too
early to determine whether or not
criminal charges will be filed
meanwhile halls's attorney did not
answer a question posed to her about a
set in 2019 in which hall's oversight of
that set was questioned for law and
crime daily i'm angenette levy
and jeanette thank you terry regardless
of who handled the gun you anticipate a
lot of civil liability in this and who's
going to be responsible
absolutely i do anticipate some lawsuits
being brought civilly first of all the
family of helena hutchins can bring a
wrongful death action what they would
need to show there is negligence and
that's pretty easy to show here because
there was this accident there was a duty
of care that duty of care was breached
and it resulted in the death of ms
hutchins so i think that we will see
something like that and there will be
exposure for the production company and
the producers and i think all of them
could possibly be sued in this kind of
case and that would include alec baldwin
because he has been listed as a producer
on the set here and julie so far we're
seeing what seems to be kind of a blame
game of who is responsible for the
incident what kind of charges criminal
charges should we expect to come and how
much responsibility do you think falls
on this assistant director david halls
so i'm not sure that we're ever going to
see criminal charges i think you know
terry's right there's no question
there's going to be a slew of civil
liability and it's there's going to be a
lot to go around for everyone that's
responsible for what happened in terms
of criminal liability you're right
everyone's pointing the fingers at each
other
and all of them in certain ways have
some level of responsibility the
question is whether or not the
prosecutor is going to believe that they
can prove beyond a reasonable doubt that
any one of them is responsible for what
they would call involuntary manslaughter
uh in new mexico now the one person that
seems to be the one they're moving away
from the most is alec baldwin we're not
hearing his name anymore we're hearing
about other people that should have
checked that gun and it should have been
checked multiple times in order to make
sure it was safe for this production all
right julian terry thank you very much
when we come back both sides rest in
florida for marquis floyd's second
murder trial
what expert witnesses say about lloyd's
state of mind before closing arguments
and welcome back to long crime daily in
florida both sides rest in marquis
floyd's second murder trial for the
death of lieutenant debra clayton
clayton was gunned down by the defendant
as she attempted to arrest him for the
murder of his ex-girlfriend shaw day
dixon logged was charged and convicted
of that murder and in that case he
avoided the death penalty and was
sentenced to life in prison if convicted
for this crime of the police officer
lloyd could face the death penalty again
both sides rested on monday evening with
the defense calling a total of 11
witnesses including the defendant lloyd
spent nearly three and a half hours on
the stand on saturday morning and
maintain that he was afraid for his life
the defendant has been outspoken
throughout the duration of the trial
speaking several times directly to the
jury before resting the defense called a
forensic psychologist to describe the
mental illness that he believes the
defendant has
and what does that mean what is
innocencia
it is a lack of insight
a lack of judgment
that attends to
uh schizophrenia uh it's
and when we talk about schizophrenia we
often talk about it in terms of
schizophrenia spectrum disorder and that
means that
with schizophrenia you can have a
variety of
a variety of symptoms manifested
that fall under that particular category
with schizophrenia
schizophrenia spectrum disorder
what you have oftentimes is a lack of
recognition this goes back to the point
of insight a lack of recognition
of mental illness a lack of recognition
of irrationality
rebuttal the state called its own
forensic psychologist who gave a
different opinion on lloyd's mental
state at the time of the shooting
based on everything you reviewed
do you have a opinion to a reasonable
degree of medical certainty as to
whether or not markeith loyd was seen at
the time of his offense on january 9th
of 2017 under florida law yes and what
is your opinion um my opinion is that he
was sane at the time of the crime
so julia rettelman two different experts
two conflicting answers how does the
jury figure it out
so we always see this and we've talked
about this a lot that sometimes when
there's two experts on both sides they
kind of cancel each other out and the
jury doesn't really consider either of
them in this case although it's a bit
different because i think that it's
going to be very hard for anyone to say
he is not guilty by reason of mental
disease or defect and keep in mind both
sides are saying that he's mentally ill
it's not like the prosecutor's saying
that he's completely mentally sane
they're saying he is still responsible
for his acts and they give their reasons
to support that i think at the end of
the day this is going to only matter at
the penalty phase because i believe he's
going to be found guilty
and terry lloyd took the stand in this
case do you think at the end of the day
it helped him
i actually think it did help him and
it's because of what julie just said she
hit the nail on the head while he was
arrogant and argumentative it was clear
to the jury i think that he demonstrated
he had paranoia and he was delusional so
yes in fact he might be a mean bad guy
and he might be arrogant and the jury
may dislike him because of that and he
did argue while he was there under cross
examination and he did come across very
negatively but i think it's going to
bolster his case that he is mentally ill
and i think his testimony may just very
well have saved his life what do jurors
think when they have a defendant talking
directly to them like that
i think it helps them because they want
to hear what the defendant has to say
what is his explanation for what
occurred and i definitely think the
defendant did that here i think he was
not nice as far as the jury is concerned
but i think he explained his rationale
all right terry and julie thank you so
much and thank you all for joining us
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we continue
to discuss justice in america
[Music]
you